fourth of july weekend that means
friends it means family it means
fireworks and of course it means food
that's really that's the best
first part
what better way to celebrate even a
barbecue ron futel joins us from wildfit
barbecue in sun city where they're
gearing up for a busy weekend is that
the sauce ron
yes what do you think we're going to try
this in just in just a moment here wait
you guys are doing sports back at the
station while i'm doing barbecue out in
the field hold on a second you did a
fine job by the way with all the sports
stuff you guys just covered steve cook
does a fine job certainly wild fig here
is the name of the place what do we have
here steve so this is our central texas
style brisket
we use 100 usda prime brisket out of a
company called brandt in brawley
california not the choice the prime
exactly the usda prime it's great stuff
okay no and i want to show the wall back
here chad i know it's going to be a
crazy turn but tell me what this is
about steve so that's our veterans wall
my partner daniel is a uh
veteran and shortly after we started
this he started what we call the
american soldier or what he calls the
american soldiers foundation of nevada a
great organization does a lot for the
local veterans you know providing
sources for food housing
clothing whatever they need any kind of
you know no
the motto is basically no veterans left
behind you know great cause yeah they do
a really really good job they got a big
gala coming up here in november as a
matter of fact okay so let's see let's
chop up the brisket here what makes as
you're doing that what makes wildfig
special different
better um
our focus is you know us as telling your
partner earlier is
primarily what we do
is we're kind of like focused on the
meat you know we instead of just doing
like barbecue from all over because i
mean we're in vegas we're in a melting
pot you know but we focus really on on
the meat itself um so the true truest
barbecue that we recognize is the
carolina barbecue with being the pork
and then the
beef out of texas so we do a central
texas style brisket we do a carolina
style pork now we've kind of evolved
because i love that the smoker that we
have outside the post oak is a great
flavor to the
pork but it's still more of a carolina
style the way we do it all right the
post oak is is the key i'm gonna try
some of this brisket okay can i is it
this am i ready it's about to get
dripping chad what do you think
it looks here we go oh that looks good
okay how many hours has this brisket
been in um these are so
the raleigh product runs a little bit
smaller so it's been about 10-12 hours
now you got the hang there you go that
is the hand that is the hang it is
hanging we are hanging with brisket so
let me get you guys more samples here
try a couple of samples here is it too
early in the morning for for barbecue
never too early for barbecue why are you
24 7 baby
oh that is
brisket is a tough meat by the way maybe
one of the toughest that is that ain't
tough that's super tender very good
that's very tender
in the whole key that one like i said
the usda prime and that post oak out
there that's what does the magic really
you know because primarily just a salt
and pepper seasoning
um
and that's it it's just the brisket is
the deal i'm getting fat today
you will definitely on this stuff here
okay it's a healthy fat though it's a
healthy fat okay so happy endi shouldn't
eat with your mouth for talk with your
mouth full of studio um anyway i am
wild fig is the name of the place here
up in
summerlin sun city summerlin
sort of sort of tucked away a little bit
you got to work to find it but it's well
worth it check it out up here steve
thank you very much happy independence
day thank you very much man and happy
entertainment
to you and the country all right thank
you thank you appreciate it we're
bringing some back
john and heather we're bringing some
back for john and heather is that okay
okay
i know i'm taking the fire station too
but john and heather with something what
about sherry
ron what about sherry and nate they've
got his at roadkill sherry might get
some later we've got a lot of places to
go
barbecue places here in town okay thank
you appreciate it
ron
one of the most enjoyable things about
independence day in the weekend is you
know you're barbecuing yourself right on
the back of the grill yeah or you could
let the pros do it but let the pros do
the fireworks
of the barbecue you could say you're a
good barbecue master but nobody's as
good as these guys
you go to like road kill the play or you
go there you buy it you stash it in the
grill itself and then you just pull it
out as if you cook it yourself
the old switch room got it well this is
right in my uh backyard so oh hey i
might just do it he said he said texas
so i think i'm
texas style north carolina carolina
style and they get their meat from
california okay